first they conquered humanity's greatest
evil
and she lay in rest
then they vanquish threats from beyond
our stars
and she lay in rest
if you'd be so kind
oh
[Music]
now our nightmares have come for us
and she must
[Music]
yes
[Music]
father
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey who ate the rest of my ramen um
there you go the next marvel game has
been revealed and joining us now to tell
us a bit more about midnight suns is
jake solomon from firaxis uh hey jake uh
thank you so much for joining us here on
o l now we saw a lot of characters in
that trailer from marvel as well as some
new faces who was that character being
resurrected and how does that tie into
this game
thank you jeff and we're very excited to
finally be able to talk about this
that character that you saw resurrected
is the hunter that's an entirely new
superhero that we designed with marvel
to be fully customizable so the player
can put themselves into midnight suns
and lead all those heroes you saw
up against the ultimate evil in our
universe which is lilith the mother of
demons i love you made a new superhero
now many fans are familiar with your
work on the xcom franchise so i'm
curious everyone wants to know what's
the style of gameplay what kind of game
is this
midnight suns is a tactics rpg
so you're not just fighting alongside
all these legends of the marvel universe
that we all know and love but you're
actually living alongside them and the
relationships that you form with those
heroes the heroes of your choice are as
important as the items and the abilities
that you bring into combat and we are
really excited to show game play on
september 1st
with the game coming out march 2022
all right i love we get to see more soon
jake thank you so much for joining us
today
well thank you jeff for having us on
opening night live